what's up guys I have a confession to me
I've never seen a single episode of any
Doctor Who I thought it was reserved for
dark corners of comic book shops and
England but I have a lot of friends and
people telling me Oh Doctor Who Doctor
Who gotta watch Doctor Who so today I
have brought in a panel of Doctor Who
fan slash mega nerds to tell me what's
the deal with the doctor starting at the
end he is a performer in a doctor who
themed improv comedy show called doctor
who live at io West in Los Angeles
Andrew Wollman thanks for having me now
she's mega nerdy and super delightful
you know her from the Nerdist and from
g4 it's Alison Haislip hello and he is
also performer in the Doctor Who live
show Chris McGowan it's fantastic to be
here so guys we're talking Doctor Who
who is Doctor Who
first of all he's the doctor yeah Doctor
Who okay and he is a two-hearted alien
Time Lord from the planet Gallifrey okay
so this is all news to me he's not just
a dude no he is actually an alien and he
has the ability to regenerate if he's
mortally wounded Oh
like Wolverine kind similar except he
doesn't end up looking the same after he
regenerates so all of the new doctors
are explained as the doctor regenerating
you a new body that's a good that's his
ability his superpower if you want to
say it I don't know if I like this cuz
like you're not gonna um be like okay
this season let's have a new Walter
White okay that's because Walter White
doesn't have super powers we've got
super powers he made the sweetest meth
in the southwest yeah yeah I'm my mind
is already getting blown because I
thought dr. who was just like the doctor
okay if he's only the doctor why is it
called Doctor Who why is this you guys
every time he introduces himself he goes
hi I'm the doctor and everyone goes
doctor him that's the greatest piece of
knowledge I picked up so far oh you are
welcome
see I thought doctor who was just a
doctor
um I thought he was just like Sherlock
Holmes travelling through time is that
good that's thank you you guys far I'm
sure
there's an alien with two hearts yeah so
there have been 50 years of Doctor Who
having never seen an episode not knowing
if I want to see an episode where would
I start it's been on over 50 years yes
it's been over seven hundred ninety
three episodes of Doctor Who comprising
about two hundred and thirty-four ish
stories this is my personal plan when I
recommend the show to other people
there's an episode called blink and if
you watch that whole episode and don't
like that episode don't watch Doctor Who
you will never like it the second school
thought is that you can begin in the
2005 reboot era with Chris Eccleston
who's the eight nine doctors the Ninth
Doctor
that's when BBC rebooted the entire
series and it's it's much more modern
now and it's the effects aren't as good
at all the charm of Doctor Who is not in
how much you're fooled by the reality of
it so I think a lot of the charm like I
mean the dog so you're saying when you
not the Daleks yes
what's a doll that's like the mortal
enemy of the Time Lords what's a Time
Lord
doctor no Doctor Who is a time yeah oh
you just called him Doctor Who agent I
did because I was speaking your language
so they had these mortal enemies called
Daleks and they kind of look like upside
down trash cans with plunger stuck in
the large salt shaker they're virus salt
shakers okay and their only purpose in
life is to exterminate everything so far
I've learned he's not named Doctor Who
he goes in a time vortex and fights
kel-tec Alex and he's from Galilee great
right right okay him and Jesus so who
would win in a battle royale of all the
doctors like I'd watch Doctor Who if
Vinnie Jones was cast as the doctor
would he be a good doctor you're missing
what doctor who was about instead of
blowing up a villain he'll talk to them
about why they shouldn't be doing what
they're doing
oh so now we're tapping into what makes
it so boring how do you say it's boring
if you've never seen an epic scene like
the black-and-white images [ __ ]
snooze but I see from Andrews shirt that
he uses lightsabers Oh like knows our
our sonic screwdrivers it's a
multi-purpose tool that uses sound waves
to do whatever the doctor needs it to do
take readings in the air of what's going
on wait what do you mean you can read
what's going on in the air you can like
sense stuff in the Oh who farted
probably inside you can determine that
yeah chemical really chemical makeup of
the air okay that might be the coolest
thing I've learned about doctors so far
you can figure out who farted so guys
what's a companion aa companion in very
brief is just someone who travels with
the doctor and so we tend to be female
the first companion in the reboot right
was a rose and rose and the doctor kind
of fell in love do they get it on not on
the show
no and the the family show families our
family show family so mommy can we watch
Doctor Who mommy
you keep saying mommy like that you need
to watch the one where the cool face is
turn into gas man Oh terrify mommy are
you my mommy
I got Miami are you my mommy on that
mommy mommy one last chance convinced me
to watch Doctor Who whatever story you
could possibly want we'll be in Doctor
Who the characters that they create on
this show are so spectacular and you
fall in love with them so easily that
you want to watch them for ages the
doctor is a MacGyver that travels
through time and space you know what
guys I'm probably not gonna watch any
Doctor Who
what's the show or movie everyone tells
you to watch but you just don't want to
tell us why in the comment section below
best answer gets a screen junkies
t-shirt I want to thank our panel you
guys were awesome I still respect you
even if I don't respect the show thanks
for coming in telling us about your
super nerdy show and I want to thank you
guys for watching I'm Hal Rudnick
bye-bye